[Música]
buenas tardes primero gracias por la
invitación para dar un poquito
arqueología de la imagen que genera las
que en esta sala imaginando la
arqueología o arqueología de la imagen
teníamos una preciosa charla de josé
también sobre la importancia de la
imagen la imagen como publicidad o la
imagen desnuda no de uno mismo la
historia o la arqueología también genera
imágenes genera imágenes que muchas
veces no nos damos cuenta de que nos
están colando no por decirlo así y
generamos estereotipos y reproducimos
estereotipos de género clasistas esos
históricos que no tienen nada que ver
con lo que realmente es nuestra
cotidianidad
la humanidad de los principios e intenta
comunicarse y interferir o modificar su
realidad con la imagen o generando
imágenes respecto de altamira o un friso
perdón un capitel románico nos están
comunicando nos están comunicando que
querían posiblemente casar que ya es
alguien que se discute con una serie de
animales para poder sobrevivir o bien
informarle cómo fue la vida de
jesucristo a las personas que no que no
que no sabían leer y después ya está
esto es el primer gran cómic de la
humanidad que es la columna trajana una
escéptica la guerra detrás ganó contra
los lo está sino lo que es actual
rumanía pues esto es una historia
política que no está transmitiendo lo
que el trajano quiso transmitir hoy
aunque nosotros como arqueólogos como
historiadores podemos perfectamente leer
o saber muchas cosas de ese segundo
siglo segundo siglo después de cristo
por ejemplo como esto cómo funcionan las
leyes romanas cómo se organizan
pertrechos y demás
y después tenemos la realidad que vemos
a cómodo vestido como como hércules y
tenemos al cómodo de erbil ya es con
vales cómodo según sigue vemos la
película que seguramente casi todo el
mundo ha visto pero que sí es muy
entretenido otra cosa no es poco menos
que estuve 34 años el poder y pasó todo
lo que pasa no lo voy a streep a por si
acaso estuvo 17 años en el poder
y eso es signo que hace e incorrecto no
creo que muchos harán así está diciendo
vida muerte es al revés hacia arriba en
horizontal este esto viene un cuadro de
1872 y a partir de ese error lo hemos
multiplicado pues así entonces
detallitos que se nos van ser van
pasando y los arqueólogos también
tenemos la responsabilidad como como
creadores de imágenes en criticar las o
en general las de forma correcta bueno
esto es todo esto tendrá que los
dinosaurios y humanos bueno y ellas
perfectamente de miradas rubias
preciosas
la última los últimos trajes de del
patrón y el paleolítico porque estamos
donde 65 millones atrás y los humanos
apenas tenemos ciento y pocos mil años
encima la tierra y si les pongo esta
imagen ya todos saben quiénes no
este es el gran enemigo de los
arqueólogos
me encantan sus películas no me las
pierdas las veo una dos tres cuatro
veces me encanta pero es el que más daño
ha hecho a la profesión de arqueólogos y
de arte colores al actual general porque
es un expoliador un explorador es
alguien que roba a más tenemos dos tipos
de arqueólogo él y ellas el uniforme de
invierno
evidentemente no ella uniforme de verano
más las herramientas son claras pistolas
látigos
y perfectamente ellos van ya quisiera
verlos excavando a ellos que venden
tejer en el invierno en esa con esos
trajes
además se lo encuentran todo entero
todo está sucio pero es pasen
impolutamente por encima
siempre llevan todo lo que encuentras
está como digo está intacto tiene un
mapa del tesoro saben llegar
y esta es nuestra realidad
nuestra realidad que rara vez nos parece
nada más saltamos hablamos con las
orejas cuando nos aparece un cacharrito
de cerámica no nada de oro ya que
evidentemente que harían lo mismo pero a
un cacharrito entero nos aparece todo
roto somos bastante la tecnología es una
aliada nuestra no es el látigo ni mucho
menos
las aspiradoras son para nosotros el
gran descubrimiento después del fuego
venía la humanidad
nos ahorra cantidad de trabajo sobre
todo dar tierra entre las costillas es
bastante complicado y eso reduce
bastante los tiempos también trabajamos
en sitios oscuros como la misma indiana
y estos son nuestros peligros algún
lagarto que se levante que sacamos
cabreados o los riegos laborales que
desde luego si hay aún alguien de por
aquí porque hicieron los ojos porque
somos bastante de soltarnos uno
y realmente cuando pongo esto de estas
imágenes porque posiblemente usted
tuviera una imagina lizada del trabajo
de arqueología posiblemente de la mitad
de los no sé para qué me digo pensarán
aventuras corrernos hoy mismo hemos
tenido una una auditoría de la hizo 2001
en la oficina de lo más divertido del
mundo
hacemos informe de impacto excavaciones
pero eso no es un tema de aventura para
la gente diseños que white eres
arqueólogo y que así como lo que me
mandan y la gente se sorprende no usted
imagen es un médico por la calle nadie
le va pidiendo el médico no va diciendo
mire está usted enfermo que quiere que
lo cure o sea los arqueólogos tampoco
con la calle oye que me apetece
descubrir algo que no se levantó con el
corazón como queriendo descubrir algo no
tenemos una tenemos unos encargos
públicos privados y sobre todo tenemos
una responsabilidad el trabajo que
hacemos en este caso
cuando hablamos del dolor internas
canario los aborígenes canarios que no
tenemos fotos que ellos hicieron no ni
mucho menos bueno dibujos y aquí tenemos
tres casos no dos hombres y una mujer se
habrían diferenciar cuál es el hombre
con la mujer
se diferencia porque aquí leer
y la mujer tiene una caja es una ropa en
forma de caja evidentemente la raza ha
generado
suele que verlos a ellos entonces sin
ropa ya jose pero un día me hago una
foto y el caso es que ellos marcan muy
bien marcaba los sexos a través
simplemente de guapetón el género a
través de las formas sexuales como se
los imaginan después los primeros
conquistadores desnudos vuelvo otra vez
agricultores con agua
y posteriormente esto es una descripción
que ella puede ser perfectamente lo que
se llama una marco pero posiblemente es
un traje de inspiración europea vale el
si de alguna forma con el traje digamos
a origen que es una faldita un capotillo
y un guapísima y esto es lo divertida
esto lo que se llama la imagen del
aborigen como rousseauniana el buen
salvaje el tio hippie que iba abrazando
árboles y donde le visitó a las cabras
y cada vez que se veía con otro aborigen
tanausú vamos allá en la cerveza que
somos gente ya allí
ese mito del buen salvaje ha hecho
muchísimo daño porque no solamente se le
aplica condiciones morales y éticas a
esas personas sino que es
hoy en imagen física nos imaginamos
posiblemente al aborigen como alguien
rubio alto guapo esbelto más con la
mirada como perdida siempre no como la
pcd de ida que no aquí se ve pero aquí
se ve como que está no sexista en que
está pensando se apagó el fuego
conseguido de la casa o no
y después esto estigmas que esto es no
sé si conoce la privativa un texto de un
escritor canario y una debacle un ave
que para arqueología porque cogieron
yacimientos donde trabajaron que les
parecían de mayor su sofisticado lo
hicieron más primitivos o en caldas por
ejemplo lo que es la guancha
ahora tenemos parte del yacimiento que
no sabemos si crecimiento o es de lo que
hicieron porque movieron casa de un lado
a otro a parte de la pampa anímica y
rompió corazones de hecho una neutra que
nosotros con el de un señor de gáldar
que dejó a su mujer y se fue italia
enamorado desde la pampa ni ni ya les
podrá contar algunas cosas más
y después claro yo creé sirviendo a este
el zarapito yo iba a ser así y media
mitad no lo hace más alto es totalmente
un cuerpo hércules y ella está preciosa
en estos mitos estas ideas que
inocentemente vamos colando es
iconografía que evidentemente vamos
colando hacen mucho daño hace mucho año
porque es muy fácil colocarlas en la
cabeza de la gente porque más se colocan
sin querer pero es muy difícil
eliminarlas o por ejemplo ya los cómics
que están viendo ahora en los aborígenes
en plan los 300 no todos no les y aquí
lo que había posiblemente una cultura
del hambre esta gente pasaba hambre
hambre de verdad se comían ratas lagarto
radio está todo lo que se moviera para
lo bien
nuestra propuesta es que estamos
trabajando de más gracias por la
fortaleza porque todo lo que hay a
nombrar ahora nace ahí es nuestra idea
era humanizar a los aborígenes y
hacerlos como las fotos de sociales
desnudarlos no pero claro es muy difícil
cuando nosotros lo que lo único que
tenemos son huesos vacías rotas una
cueva con dos pinturitas pero pues
tenemos mucho sentido común y podemos
comparar con otras con otras sociedades
no esto fue una una cocina tenemos un
contenedor para meter restos
arqueológicos que nos parecía muy feo
tenerlo delante del centro y llevamos a
matilla de esas botas del montaje y
cogimos un par de imágenes de una visual
que ahora les pondré una parte pero las
imágenes que dibujamos está esta imagen
aquí no hay no hay nobles en estas
imágenes no hay no hay es un hombre y
una mujer le podemos poner los atributos
que queramos pero hemos querido
el noble serlo en el sentido de que vea
porque parece que en los 650 algunos
libros que se publican sobre
descendencia origen todos descienden de
fernando guanarteme nadie desciende de
pobre de la cueva de que estaba al fondo
del barranco todos son hijos o nietos de
noble seguro que el que sabe que es del
pobre no lo dice pues esto es lo mismo
hemos querido normalizar a los
aborígenes a los indígenas
esto es dentro de la nueva exposición
que tenemos son una manual y un faycán
no se dice pero se ríen parece que si
eres alguien en la vida no te puedes
reír
gente
aborígenes riéndose gente más mayor
niños si es bien en los cómics y demás
no aparece el niño y sabemos que la
natalidad es brutal
haciendo cosas cotidianas ir a buscar el
agua picando piedras porque está en la
cárcel y no va a hacerlo molina
o algo que la gente llama la atención
esa labor en canarias
así de metro y medio que la boca así
y los perros son así
lo que pasa que bueno también puedes a
ponerlos
o situaciones cómicas como para hacer
que uno esté en la carne está ahí pero
que dicen y por qué no puede pasar eso
porque tenemos que pintarlo siempre como
si el mundo se fuera a comer mañana o
bueno el primer mensaje de whatsapp que
recién a eso
no está en nuestro proyecto espíritu me
haga según me haga ahora sabemos que es
mía ya es un disco sagrado que acabamos
poco menos que sabemos ya en esta última
semana sabemos dónde estuvo eso es otra
charla vale pero el acrónimo de un haga
aquí invención de anna y una
investigación genética análisis fuimos
capaces de sacar todo eso en un proyecto
que consistía intentar recuperar la cara
de una persona
de la fortaleza como lo hicimos esto es
un antecedente esto es un trabajo que
hizo una escocia a partir de un cráneo
fin se es en blanco y negro y plano
porque porque además tiene pequitas la
ponen como blanca la ponen como muy
blanca
este señor grau bassas saca dos cráneos
de asalto de la fortaleza en el siglo 19
ésta es una mujer de entre 30 y 35 años
creemos que era una señora unam agua de
una harimaguada que se decía los
incidentes 80 esto es una cultura que
además era la fortaleza que acabó en
parís la tenemos pérdidas esto es una
réplica que parece que va vestida
fíjense que no tiene ombligo en la
mayoría los ídolos que vemos tiene
ombligo estaba más vestida y queremos
que esa señora era algo importante en
esa comunidad era una señora que tenía
una digamos unos usos lo que pueden ser
asimilable a nuestras monjas no a las
monjitas nuestra
es un trabajo interdisciplinar o
arqueólogas arqueólogos en este caso
arqueolã y entró por loca tere tere
delgado del museo canario que se encargó
de estudiar el digamos toda aquella
información que nos pudiera el cráneo
tenía un golpe en la cabeza bastante
fuerte del lado izquierdo
la salud bucal era mala malísima
sea usted si se imaginaba un aborigen
riéndose pocos dientes les van a ver
vale
el cambio 977 como se enumeró en el
siglo 19 lo tenemos que perder un
pequeño tajo les juro que nos dolió lo
que no estaba escrito y a partir de ahí
se hizo la secuencia genética que la
hizo rosa fregel entre stanford y
universidad la laguna tardamos dos años
en ser proyecto
pablo es pablo aparicio riesco el
restaurador tiene empresa de
restauración digital en la península y
es quizás de las personas más punteras
en trabajos de este tipo no solamente en
restituciones faciales que ha trabajado
para el alma para un ser clásico
nacional sino además han disfrutado de
arquitectura no
y esto es lo que nosotros a partir de
este cráneo nos sale una señora que va
vestida de blanca de blanco porque las
aguadas van vestidas de blanco según las
crónicas del siglo 16 tiene unas
trencitas como aparecen en los ídolos
y tiene una cara que no es ni rubia no
es ni ni los ojos claros y pelo oscuro
el 75 de la población sabemos que es
pelo oscuro este es oscura por el sol
si no cogen se la recomiendo que le dio
un vistazo a la página web de la ciudad
de artesanía del cabildo grancanario
verán población de gran calidad al final
de lecciones de principio del 20 y dirán
que nos gran cara dirán que bolivia que
es perú porque la gente son los retos
morenos
así del trabajo de estar continuamente
expuestos al agresor
esto es la preguntaron que cómo la
bautizamos la señora de mi área de agua
de ayer un tema un poco tengo les tengo
que decir para poner un poco los dientes
largos que el martes pasado nos dieron
el busto si es un gusto hiperrealista
estamos encantados en breve después de
las elecciones no se puede presentar
nada se hará
y esto es un poco el trabajo que hicimos
para qué sirve esto
y esto para que pues sirve para
normalizar
a los indígenas canarios porque elegimos
una mujer porque siempre se eligen
hombres se persona hombre los nobles son
los que salen son los que van por
delante la mujer tiene una posición
pasiva están sentadas están con los
niños parece que eso es lo único que
saben hacer y nos parece interesante
destacar el papel de la moza del siglo
quinto después de cristo que ya tiene un
papel importante en lo que es lo que
sería la fortaleza y como me gusta
reírme de todo
pero también tenemos que reír de
nosotros mismos esto es una imagen que
hicieron en internet y se la pedía hasta
el dueño y el ver ver streisand que me
parece buenísimo
no sé a qué pues
a este ritmo las imágenes importan tanto
cuánto nos influye no hay niños hay un
par de años en la sala a la lenin
y lo que les digamos ahora se les va a
quedar en el hábito y yo pensar que las
originan todos altos rubios quedan como
yo
bueno yo quería un poquito más pero es
importante la imagen que consumimos y
muchas veces cuando elevamos la imagen
con todo el buen hacer equivocamos un
ejemplo y terminó cuando se extraen la
aguatinta hace de 10 11 años hay el
audiovisual en los aborígenes para
rapado por un lateral yo tengo amigos de
amigos no quiero decir que esas personas
en mis amigas se raparon igual porque
ellos querían ser orígenes
sé que hay mucho vale
pero influye la imagen
no estoy inventando nada es marketing
especialización pero también la historia
que tiene que ver mucho la imagen vale
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]